citizens of the reject Nation welcome to
another action spectacular the two Jack
disc guys doing reactions in the game
going Gregor and watch dread Greg has
seen it as a child I saw it as a child I
remember little to nothing but it being
a cinematic Masterpiece that's all you
need to remember it was designed for
four-year-olds so it's been like 31
years I think I missed an entire comic
book series because there's two of them
I've not seen either I knew I hadn't
seen the second one I've never seen this
I haven't seen the second one so we'll
do a first time watching for the Carl
Urban one I love sitting on this side I
feel like it's stretching out this side
of my neck a little more trash I very
very much love the comic book uh one of
my buddies jock has brought the comic
book back to life it is a very beautiful
book it is very historically like loved
it's one of those cult Comics that has
really endured the test of time so we're
gonna dive in and uh we're gonna see how
it goes are you excited you didn't say
any of the stuff nope didn't and
remember hit that like hit that
notification intro going to
that's true that's true but I'm gonna go
just from the bottom here remember to
hit that notification Bell hit that like
button so you know that you want to see
dread too which is really just dread
reboot and leave a comment below
especially with action movies you want
us to watch so let us know if there's
anything you're like I bet these guys
haven't seen black leave a comment below
and which dread do you like more this
one or the new one with uh Joel Ken Carl
Urban and all of his growly glory
I suppose though we don't have a patreon
anymore we're out of patrons they're all
dead and if you want to watch this
completely with us from front to back
start to finish and see me and Greg's
resting faces
become a patron and be super sexy over
there with us as we dive into dread that
intro is going to be called Coy's failed
intro
[Music]
oh I missed this logo I always thought
that looked like Arnold Schwarzenegger
like they yeah the night in the face of
them
so bad now I'm not gonna unsee it
because he's so chiseled and he's got
the big cheekbones and like that I see
it
you love Comics I love these things they
make
yeah look at this reference in the
comics more than the average comic movie
this is fantastic
is this suggesting we're stepping into a
comic book it feels like it we're going
into the between the panels in the third
millennium the world changed climate
Nations all were in upheaval yes
transformed into a poisonous scorched
desert known as the cursed Earth
millions of people crowded into a few
mega cities
bands of Street Savages created violence
the justice system could not control
law as we know it collapsed
a society ruled by a new Elite Force
they were the police jury and
executioner all in one
they were the judges whose voice is that
it's the butt to butt guy from Requiem
for a Dream for sure right all right I
didn't say it because it's on YouTube I
want to demonetize but that's the scene
that's okay thought ahead
ah actual models
it sounds like Dune Vibes Diane Lane's
in this that's right
I remember that shocking Aspen prison
shuttle docked
what he's the first character you see I
would never have guessed six-month
sentence Aspen prison served welcome
back citizen your living assignment is
why block Heavenly Haven red quad ah
he's returning to society
[Music]
uh don't you miss when future movies
used to do this stuff now they're like
what's a realistic future
look at that like overly done yeah this
is just cool stacks on Stacks also some
Fifth Element Vibes
one of us will reference Blade Runner
eventually and we'll get there wait till
a raining shot man
[Music]
Statue of Liberty is just right there
just chilling this is built around it
oh my God this is just LA on the weekend
recycled food
ill be kind and peaceful to each other
eat recycled food ew
what's his name Dexter Morgan's Dad yeah
James something James yeah
maybe I should
[Music]
go there
block war block war it's a war on their
block
[Music]
uh it's just like a free-for-all of
death because it doesn't look like
they're specifically attacking anyone
they were just doing their own thing
judges
it's a pretty Slumber shot It's gotta be
him
[Music]
foreign
practical effects here yeah I really
like it yeah yeah through the fire
[Music]
[Laughter]
yes come and get us
he's crazy
the effect of legal range is 200 meters
you're safe you can still be shot so it
hurt
waiting for backup it's here
I'm lost
[Music]
got how cool that gun was practical
Smooth Criminal
foreign
[Music]
[Laughter]
that's an official move it must be all
right double whammy code 457 resisting
arrest 20 years
thank you
and code 3613
the first degree murder mystery church
so much judging let me guess life
death death
yeah this movie's perfect did they just
kill Robert Schneider off camera he was
our Island
thanks so
damn it oh that was Diane Lane it's good
for the environment and okay for you
please make your selection insert your
credit in the slot oh I see his voice
go by e you are in the way of the circle
Droid what boy am I glad to see you
hopeful sabotage of a public Droid
that's six months citizen let's see a
unicorn oh my God Church you are
unreasonable he was trying to live and
survive five years five years
[Music]
who is this guy die legally
comedy I can't tell if it's like a
commentary on blob
like the Gilded Eagle on his shoulder
like what is this okay it's up it's like
intentionally funny
so much
you may start at East Joseph face reveal
the Mandalorian
oh my God it's Sylvester Stallone I
never would have known
you really remember what you taught me
sir you were my finest student history
starting tomorrow you're going to spend
two days a week at the Academy not
killing people killing student Achilles
dudes
it's about Judge Dread learning not to
kill Snape goes back to school unfair
incarceration all the time
I don't cross anything
I'm a ghost and we're both prisoners
here oh
it was just very familiar but but can't
play some Our Mysterious benefactor has
sent you a package
deactivate Shield
auto guns only oil guns reactivated
Warden Miller said Lord and Miller Lord
and Miller it's a premonition
what is that
that's an ancient puzzle
that contains the meaning of life why
would you have your Shields down around
this guy why would you scan the side of
your thumb instead of the front of it
what is the meaning of life
foreign
that's the meaning of life
[Applause]
[Music]
voice not recognized under the throat no
security override and unlocked
Stormtroopers get in there you'll miss
he's not in this tiny space he must not
be oh there it is
that every judge must take outside these
City walls and there spend your last
remaining days taking law to the Lawless
that's a retirement dying alone outside
that's winning
you made it sound like our lives are
practically over
you haven't gotten used to the isolation
the Curry's lit
loneliness no one is supposed to be
alone all the time haven't you ever had
a friend it's cold as ice
once
I rested him he broke the law Jay what
10 years
I judged him
he is hilarious in this movie is he
aware I don't know he's so funny what is
the genre he's the best park it's so
good so funny oh it's a wide boy who's
that Stormtrooper
focused on that for a reason one of them
yes
[Music]
even altarped up he could still aim that
well impressive it is impressive I don't
know why he took off his dog tags though
he was wearing them in the prison
they seemed important to him at the time
now it's played now it's Blade Runner
Blade Runner bizarre
good casting though see this guy looks
very drawn he looks like a comic
character yeah it's a good call like The
Duality
between him and Stallone both looking it
was inevitable
20. hello this is antiques I thought
they destroyed all these ABC Warriors
during the last war
ABC Warriors
hey wait a second don't touch it that's
programmed to only recognize a judge's
hand you touch that it will take your
arm off
I must be a church
why is that Kellen but try to kill
everyone come on
are there giant Mech robots in this
you know cool it's been 31 years
if you don't remember that he's pretty
cool
you have an Iron Giant coming in oh now
he's programmed too
it's all six he just hotwired a robot
we're allowed to happen if they don't
work oh cool yes
[Music]
I don't care what Aaron says that looks
awesome that is so badass
[Music]
no
I wonder if he was framed nope that
seems like what's up
he was judged ball man was just like
[__] this well he talked [__] about him
out judge Hershey call control for an H
web you're gonna tell me
this is your fourth violation bar breath
you are minutes how do you please not
guilty I knew you'd say that
wait a second what are you doing grenade
grenade no way
first violation to so forth I blow it up
Superman is so extreme
I just blew up his card
that's so much destruction of property
Madrid you're under arrest what's the
charge
abusing the law this man is clearly
innocent he just blew up a car easiest
cop to frame ever in front of Rick ruin
of course you can frame this guy there's
a blown up Lamborghini fights everything
is the worst defense I judged him have
you selected someone to defend you judge
Hershey got the academy she was at the
top of her class in interpretation of
Law and I trust her the facts will come
out at the trombone I'll personally make
sure of that oh when the guy had the gun
taken out there that dude's face was in
the uh no the it was the oh yeah the
yeah the guy killed the journalist yeah
yeah
it was a hit we know that the uniform of
a judge can be counterfeit and that the
badge can be duplicated and since
neither the video nor the audio in this
presentation can identify the accused my
objection to this video being allowed as
evidence in this case
is no one aware that a former judge
turned criminals
maybe it's a coincidence Maybe
should we alert them
a lot of people died
as a result of the DNA coding on those
bullets the DNA is a perfect match for
judge Joseph dress
what how
do you steal someone's DNA how could I
have been so wrong correct both of them
homicidal I dread this
the day I have long dread oh wait he
just said both of them are homicidal
He's the bad guy yeah it's his brother
it's his brother yeah he just said it
brother wouldn't be a perfect match
surprised they just reveal all that [__]
for you
how's the brother a perfect match though
that's not a DNA works there is a way
out chief justice A Long Walk that's a
death sentence judge Griffin you're a
retirement grants you the power to save
dread's life I know this guy's a good
guy but he comes across so evil he's
evil I don't know man
tribunal finds Joseph dread guilty
that's chalk
did they say the DNA match was dread or
Joseph dread did they find Joseph dread
guilty
okay that's not how DNA works it has
long been our custom
to carry out the last order of a
retiring senior judge and so
I stepped down way to go dread just made
everything worse now the big evil guy's
gonna be the big bad come on as it is
written Justice Griffin this trial has
been a farce I demand an appeal you will
accept the Court's decision
is very believable in Smith acting
let us armor be taken from him and all
his scarf of Justice
[Music]
forever
I thought they wanted this to be the
first movie oh yeah they're like
stripping from being judged act too
[Laughter]
show a bunch of comic frames let him
take the law he served so well to those
who have it not so now he's gotta go
walk into Exile because he was a judge
what a weird system because it was his
trade the last order was to keep him
alive
thank you
what a boring way to live He's gotta go
fight a sand worm
oh my goodness cool visual they're
constrained by the time but the visuals
are really cool like well production
designed and stuff definitely a lot of
striking like dystopian sci-fi imagery
I can't believe you were ever a baby
and the baby
uh the one guy he judged his brother was
also his friend I'd assume that's who he
was talking about we were supposed to
meet someplace safe
oh
you mess with him you mess with me
the robot makes the whole movie for me
Hammond had to be silenced he found out
about Janus but I could have used red he
worships the law yeah let me see what
it's like to freeze his ass off in Aspen
let him see what it's like to be me
there's a lot of work to be done I like
the exposed cables on that it's really
cool yeah you want chaos I
beginning
yeah
in the beginning it's really unhinged I
don't know what he's aiming for exactly
but all right you know he's uh the blank
we got two bad guys stuff I'm uh
mustache twirl with throwing stuff
this is legit looks like an episode of
Mandalorian
like this could pass for a Disney
pleasure that's great
he broke out of that easily
oh dread you looking out
he punches very hard oh no
[Music]
oh no
oh my God
if I oppressive his nostrils are they
consume
what are they hoping for I think feed
him I said I'm gonna get a city boy oh
yeah you're probably right he looks
familiar that actor too at the cut face
awake neat good
we're running out of stickers oh my God
it's becoming a Rob Zombie movie they
played White Zombie earlier
oh Lord
you have flashed us indeed damn the
design of this one guy is really hard to
take your eyes off yeah he's cool excuse
me we're not together
the Practical in his chest is so cool
it's disturbing as hell
that come with a four cancer
nice
[Music]
ouch ouch
oof Hallelujah
can it be that from the city of the
Fallen
and we really don't do it it sounds like
we have a believer
cut him down maybe the law doesn't make
mistakes but I'm free you're toast
actually your toast
your new friends they're cannibals
laughs
fresh
foreign
[Music]
oh
my goodness
let's see if he just kills these guys
guilty
corrupt cops
all right
[Music]
it's like a digital Rambo gun
they didn't do anything wrong just doing
the job like he would yeah they're dead
though guilty
[Music]
Max von Saito
from the outside Joseph
together again I walked 300 miles I
found you my son
what
did not expect it did not expect it
they brought him back to kill him with
Frankenstein he was around for like a
second at a scene of reunion
[Music]
illegal use of city electricity
do you say that
whoa cool that's a great shot
it's full of anomalies really clever
ones too
somebody must have used the CGI terminal
in a scan quad to make this 20 years ago
whoa CGI terminal
it's real it's the baby
is he made in the lab is the guy a clone
so he has the same DNA that would make
more sense not a brother wait is dreaded
which one's the Clone are they both
alone
four decades ago DNA samples were taken
from the original castle one was chosen
mine we altered it to enhance this
quality yes
I created you
it is Blade Runner is that why he
behaves like such a crazy Soldier
because he's not a person whose programs
in that experiment but something went
wrong genetically mutated to the perfect
criminal oh that it wasn't the one that
got Justice and for his crimes you
judged him he was his brother he didn't
realize his brother was his brother
he put that together remarkably fast
that other guy was asking him
[Music]
I feel like we're watching what should
have been a part two oh 100
like no introduction of the judges no
introduction of these countries
like the the brother Discovery sequel is
100 a second movie
the fall of the city didn't happen for
us
[Music]
hiding in the dumps
that's such cool character design
there is a solution project James this
Council tried to play God once before
this whole sailed Slaughter of Judges
continues there won't be a council it's
kind of like a Nazi a little bit of
Desperate Times fascist regime
all right you ready kid
no it's your brain
there's a maniac loose in this city
there's one out here too
this did me I wouldn't be here in the
first place and I'm gonna stay here
until I'm caught or until you apologize
the law can't apologize
[Music]
you're not the law anymore now apologize
I think I deserve that
I've never apologized
is it a comedy he's so funny
[Music]
not smart
it's the first time it was a tad intense
yeah that was a moment yeah I'm alive
[Laughter]
great that's so funny
oh I could see how Schneider started a
career from this I just really he's
actually really sorry
I'm lost is this the bathroom
why are you taking off his clothes
time for this
[Laughter]
that was such good delivery
that was so funny
[Laughter]
like wasn't sarcastic at all it's like
no judgment or something
[Music]
Brothers clones
this is a surprisingly great dude
they like work really well together good
job casting director yeah
[Music]
how are they staying on it
wow what did come first this or Fifth
Element there's a lot of crossover yeah
[Music]
Oh I thought he shot his own the car I
think they hit the edge of the thing and
it launched back
well timed
I love how he's just killing other
innocent literally people that did his
job I know he's like I am the law but
kill the law for doing the law
there also is co-workers like he knows
these people
happy birthday
[Music]
murder him's ready
that's a bad guy you just killed I my
mind says you guys had lunch together
before
you know the truth who are you dread
said that shut up
we're dying out there 108 judges in 48
hours
he killed 20 of them
we know they're not all judges there's
just something below that Central take
this DNA sample wasn't part of our plan
jeez the next batch of Genius judges are
not gonna be the puppets that you want
they're gonna be my brothers and sisters
and mine to control
wait what a dumbass in front of that I'm
gonna pull out this little gun in front
of this Iron Giant murder machine this
is a really long 90 minutes oddly
for how much action for how much fun
dialogue we've laughed a lot
very long 90 but I still feel the run
time and it's it's less than like an
animated film like how
foreign
[Music]
oh no
they just kill Rob Schneider we thought
it before
[Music]
how does dread ever friends with this
guy he seems like he's just so much yes
the worst yeah he's like Mr long until
you evolve into this like what send in
the Clones
what are we about to see send in the
Clones done this is just a bunch of
hymns there's no like process oh there's
no okay never mind they're cooking I
thought it was a bunch of him just done
cooked
head off instead
[Music]
oh he's a hacker
what that Rob Schneider's a hacker oh oh
okay
[Music]
thank you [__] nicely done Central I
said first set of clothes the cloning
process is not finished Judge Rico the
Clones will be only 60 complete what are
we gonna do it's 60 just gloop around
yeah
[Music]
cat fight
[Applause]
[Music]
they behave like Monsters 100
not like these two guys who are also
close
they get empathy last
come on
[Music]
every every cat fight you gotta say you
gotta say [__] she just say judge [__]
I think she said judgment but I like
that better this is Judge [__] judge
[__]
oh they were in the central Liberty the
whole time I did not realize that I'm
the only one
Blade Runner right now
freedom
[Music]
Liberty conscious thought in the brain
of Liberty
way to go drug dread a little rounds
exhausted
smart
[Music]
then he fell on 12 innocent people
adding to his murder rate of five an
hour we have to reconstitute the council
we'd like you to consider the first
position of Chief Justice
oh that's great he gets all the credit
I taught him everything he knows dread
is he just going back to work right now
he's good
no she went for it the truth I'm
probably a much better kisser
okay come on let's go will you uh
Queen by a cash machine
I feel emotions
he's just gonna pose
yeah
oh I'm gonna just close my eyes here for
a minute
I fall off the Liberty building again
I'll just post here
oh Jesus wow
you did it that was I've seen a comic
movie I've never seen before these are
always fun wow oh God that was uh that
was a long 90 man I know
I'm shocked
that a movie can be that short long
I mean it's not great it's not great but
it is fun it's fun but it is fun it is
fun I'm really glad I saw it I think in
this context it is the ideal way to
watch it I don't think I would have made
it through without you no I don't know
if I would have just been like odd dread
like I don't know that that would have
gotten finished all right man well
Sylvester Stallone would you think of
George I don't know if he knew the movie
or if we knew I I don't know if Stallone
made a drama and we all saw it as a
comedy or if the director like he was so
sincere in a lot of that delivers funny
like I don't know what do you think to
this day Stallone thinks this is like a
drama
ah I'd be curious to know
I know that people don't like this movie
I feel good about having fun with it
knowing it's not great
yeah I didn't it couldn't help but feel
like it was
um I mean I love Stallone in it though I
love still owning it I just don't know
if he knew what it was he's the best
part for all the reasons you wouldn't
say he's the best he's so because he's
so committed he's so sincere he's so
committed and I respect it because I
feel like he's gotta have some level
like does Stallone have awareness or is
he like Vin Diesel that's what I mean is
this a casting director going I'm very
clever or is this a cash director going
like this is what the movie needs you
know what I mean yeah yeah cause he's
because he even worked really well off
Rob Schneider and the performance even
came more to life when Rob Schneider is
like the panicky finicky oh yeah and
he's super stoked he's saying awesome
one-liners yeah but he's even saying
one-liners that are like intentionally
funny to bounce off 100 Rob Schneider
and I thought they they said that was
probably the most surprising part the
Buddy Duo between the two of them that I
never would have it's a felt it was
really Charming I wonder if people like
it as much as us and they're putting
there's there's questionable things
where I'm like I wonder if that's a
thing that Coy and Greg like but others
because we're like this Duo really
worked for me I also love the Practical
effects I mean we said it a lot but I
was so enamored with the World building
they really made a cool set and like
lived in it everywhere and despite what
you think about uh uh Rico
Starship Troopers despite what you think
about Rico uh this is like the 90s name
I think it was a commentary on the Rico
laws of the time oh was it yeah you know
like Rico laws like when you get
arrested and like one of your other
known associates get arrested you can
charge the whole group with that crime
yeah I think it was a commentary on like
what the times were with Law and Order
in the mid 90s like the Rico laws got
drafted around the time like Tupac was
killed so it was a big commentary on
like gang Warfare and then there was
also like the three strikes law that was
the same time that's because the opening
was about like the guy getting five
years for something ridiculous so I feel
like it was a commentary on like RICO
law and the three strikes maybe yeah or
I'm thinking about it
because I felt like this movie wanted to
be a Paul verhoven film right it wanted
to be Paul who did like Robocop and
Starship Troopers which has a uh
satirical awareness about it and I think
it wanted to be that but it got
condensing to make it a 90-minute action
film it still drags at times
surprisingly
what I'd take out either
it's not like scenes I think you would
need to add stuff in and make stuff
better I don't think it's about taking
make it better everything's about taking
stuff out I think it's about making
things more interesting sure and and
instead of
um you know take because there was
something about once the loan's taken
it's so serious that it was funny
because you say ridiculous [__] and
giving insane convictions
yeah every time they'd show me they'd be
like look at his eyes and the strings
would swell that he'd say like a line
that would be like a Wanderer from Mel
Gibson and Lethal Weapon yeah it didn't
have it didn't have a the whole tone
didn't have awareness right
um so Rob Schneider was funny Stallone
uh seemed this alone seemed to I don't
know I'm just gonna I'm gonna Edge
towards the loan I don't know I don't
awareness
I'm gonna go 60 40. yeah I'm gonna I'm
just gonna give him the benefit of the
death because it was just working so but
it's only working
uh uh like 30 years later right right
now or was it like back then people were
like he's funny you know that's a great
question did audiences see this movie
then or are we seeing it because we live
in this meta era yeah yeah yeah that's
what that is a big question mark
um I don't know maybe the RICO thing is
actually because maybe the comics did
yeah I think I just saw the name Rico is
listed by one of the credits oh really
yeah so maybe maybe it's not as hideous
I wanted to give a credit oh yeah yeah
it's just the guy's name I'm like oh
he's a commentary
or the name Rico hey uh yeah I like um I
like the guy who played he played John
Gotti in a movie
I think the movie is called Gotti um
no he did not play John God in the
Travolta movies
oh Travolta plays Gotti yes oh I thought
he was just in a movie named God I know
he played Dottie yeah oh two goddess hey
it's Arnold Arnold's on screen um yeah
so John he played Gotti in that uh but I
I haven't seen that gaudy movie I just I
remember the cover now is so and and
it's not like there's any plan to ever
react to this guy
that's awesome cheese it was something
to come but should we watch demolition
man because I hear it's great I mean
I've seen him I I remember Demolition
Man pretty well okay I just know there's
a Taco Bell in it
yes that's all I know about it because
of the FBI I don't remember Demolition
Man
I don't remember the Taco Bell there's a
whole thing where they opened a Blade
Runner Taco Bell I mean a Demolition Man
Taco Bell in the style of it and
everybody was all excited and I was like
cool oh not ringing a bell oh cool yeah
I mean I just I mean I love the two of
them oh it's so Judge Dread and uh
practical the music the music was so
good if it was him it was great uh yeah
we just didn't take the time to look at
the credits look at the [__]
difference in the scores 4.2 000 people
gave it four and a half star or like
wild four and a half stars for four
point two thousand people but IMDb 5.6 I
mean it's fun I had a great time it's a
fun movie it's a group mute like this
would not be fun to just sit and watch
the thing is the World created I don't
know how appreciated it was back then
yeah because even when you compare it to
Fifth Element The Fifth Element feels
more there's a lot of practical there's
a lot of practical uh it still has feels
like there's even more seeds yet but it
just looks better and the movie feels
like those worlds exist like I buy the
mythology I buy the aliens I buy the
locations whereas like so good that
one's incredible that's such a good
movie great movie but that's a little
bit more like oh I get why this is here
whereas this is like that looks cool
yes yes and I think like we can
appreciate it now because of what Cinema
has devolved into yeah because there's
nothing paid it was yeah so much CGI
that we can watch this and go this looks
awesome how sad is that we're like wow
that's cool they built a thing yeah like
the bar shouldn't be just have it be
able to be touched and Max von Cito is
all right he's all right it was all
right I was real sad when he like came
back just to die but then it was like
they got the exposition the designs of
the I think they said Angel family yeah
they were great I recognized two of them
the dad and the youngest son looked
really familiar oh yeah the guy plays
Rico's fine
um I don't know I've never read a Judge
Dredd comic has this it's got the energy
it's got that
like there's a lot of that heavy
overbearing like this is very quotable
it feels like it's in caps it's got a
lot of those like block off frame like
so it must be somewhat intense
like you know what I mean like I doubt
Salon read the comics so I I hope the
director went like this is Hardcore 90s
whereas like I don't know if Stallone
was like I don't know if they're making
fun of it because they've read okay yeah
yeah because they they start off with
the comments they clearly someone loved
them and as someone who hasn't read the
comics I'm like maybe this is like the
comics I don't know where maybe is that
what they're going for this is like an
undervalued film for an adaptation I
just I mean I hear the new one's amazing
is incredible right so I mean that we'll
see what what we will compare those two
and know what the level of satire it is
yeah because that's that's but I think
that left this left such a bad taste to
people's mouth that no one can't
remember that's the problem
dread loves it because yeah like Carl
was out as much of a household name and
and like I remember the posters for it
and I'm like this looks like this was
supposed to look like I don't watch it
really Sylvester Stallone one but I
would love to see a sequel of this I
would love to see it it feels like a
sequel yeah that was the problem with it
was that like like I've I've heard that
when you're making a TV show one of the
great ways to get your
one of the great ways to do a TV show a
cool tip I've heard is not always the
case
um but one of the greatest I've heard
really make sure you get to know your
characters is like write your pilot and
then write your second episode in your
second episode should be your pilot and
I think like there's a way you can mix
and match that that way you really know
the character and yeah but here I'm like
well first off you remove them from
being judged dreads like a half hour
20 minutes and then all this like
crumble of the city and uh the the the
Anarchy of the hierarchy dissembling
I'm like well I don't really know this
world
I'm like I get that there was an opening
crawl to tell me about Judges I don't
really know what this world is a voice
over opening curl does not replace the
first movie yeah yeah and it definitely
felt like they were just like get to it
and the stakes of him being banished I
mean it takes of backspawn cedo's
character being banished and Dread being
uh framed and and like oh this would be
the sequel where like Dread is no longer
the man of the law he's done so much and
now he's outside the lawn and he's
outside the city walls that's a good
sequel story and like almost everything
here would have been better for a sequel
or a longer movie with better scenes so
that way all these scenes could feel
like wow we've really built us some
craziness or like yeah the third Act of
this would have been all that those
elements yeah but we had to get there
we'd never got there the build up with
the clones and what a cast of like 90s
like eight like hit like hard hitters
and like the guys that I don't recognize
but are like character actors from that
era so clearly they like put a lot into
it but something missed Diane Lane's
attractive dying Lane
um oh my God 30 years is just gorgeous I
mean we all know Diane Lane is actually
an incredible actress yeah this is not
her best form not she's learning but can
you really say that about like Max
valencito who is another legendary actor
you know uh so yeah yeah the this was uh
it's got some cheesy ass dialogue I
laughed a lot awful pacing at times
um robot it was awesome because when it
wasn't it when it was not like I thought
the guy played Rico did a good job but
at the end of the day robot was great
well they clearly a highlight but when
when it when judge Dred when that's the
thing is like when Stallone was whatever
you think about Stallone he's got
something about his Charisma that
whatever he's on screen when he's on
screen the movie's pretty entertaining
but when when he's not on screen and
it's like focusing on other characters
it's kind of boring yeah say something
great yeah it gets a little boring even
when you're like with Max von Sito who's
a great actor yeah like movies but in
this world I'm gonna go back to Stallone
because like Stallone is the world so it
like really feels like you need to get
back to his Ridiculousness nor does it
feel like yeah like I hate to say it but
it doesn't feel like a Vin Diesel choice
for you like it's got to be about me you
know right it still felt like it was an
ensemble movie yeah so focus on other
characters and stuff it didn't feel like
Sylvester Stallone being selfish make
sure every shot's meeting yeah yeah uh
so I had fun I will probably not watch
it again for a decade but I like I could
enjoyed I took 30 years for me to get
around to this but I want to see the SEC
I do want to accept it for the new one I
do want to see this too but was I feel
like
I feel like if if the sequel's as good
as people are saying it is
it will be even it feels like it would
be even more appreciative for us because
we just enjoyed that and yeah
it's gotta be like so much if if if if
we just hop right to there maybe not
love it but the joy we got from this
elevating no my God yeah I'm so excited
yeah I give this movie like a success I
was thinking of three to five because I
read it yeah so the same if out of ten
I'd say like six three it like passes
but man is it close yeah same yeah
um
well hopefully dread the new one is not
us going like how is this so long and
yet short but we're gonna check that out
next uh that's like a hard R yeah here
it's been brutal I think it's like one
location or something
in terms of like you're in one location
in a building and Olivia thoroughly wide
door and Lena Headey I hear something oh
yeah so yeah we're in for some good
times we're checking that out next thank
you very much for joining us on Greg and
koi watch action movies if you want to
watch the limitation man let us know if
you want us to watch something else in
the comments let us know because we
enjoy these action movie Journeys we
will see you very soon reject Nation
much appreciated bye
[Music]
thank you